new USA Today investigation uncovers how
the US Olympic Committee and the
national governing bodies under its
umbrella allegedly failed to enforce
bans on youth coaches accused or
convicted of sexual misconduct they
found six coaches were still active in
their sport despite being banned from
coaching that included one who served
jail time for lewd and lascivious
conduct with a child
the writers say the Olympic Committee
vowed repeatedly to fix its child
protection system but the investigation
found that gaping holes remain in a
statement the USOC said quote we have
worked with each of our national
governing bodies to ensure all
information on sanctioned individuals is
provided to the US Center for safe sport
it also said it expects a comprehensive
database will be available early next
year
Nancy are more the lead reporter on the
USA Today sports investigation joins us
with the latest this is an explosive
investigation it is stunning Nancy and
the first question is how is this even
possible that these coaches were allowed
to continue working nobody's keeping
track of them they're banned and then
it's it's like oK we've done our job and
then it's forgotten about the case that
we led with - gerald murphy people
high-ranking officials at both the US
Olympic Committee and USA Taekwondo
knew about it and he was banned in -
2014 four days later his wife filed
paperwork to take over the gym nobody
thought to follow up and that happens
far too often and they get away with it
because they know nobody's keeping exact
and I think as a parent you think
somebody has bedded all of these people
no that's not the case not necessarily
and it's did most of these governing
bodies because the USOC has
traditionally said it's not our job
safe sport says will issue the sanctions
but then you have to enforce them and
most of these governing bodies they
don't have the resources they don't have
the staff they don't have the knowledge
to follow up and make sure that these
people are staying out of sports after
they've been banned more than 900
coaches were banned for a variety of
reasons it took you a month to find six
who were banned for sexual misconduct so
do you believe there are many more out
there absolutely why has the USOC or any
of those individual sports not created a
data
to track these coaches that's a great
question because this is it's been
something that's been suggested going
back from 2010 was one of the first
working groups that they looked at if
they talked about it and for a variety
of reasons said okay we're not going to
do it and it's still not done you know
Congress brought this up in the hearings
this spring and they're saying we we
plan to have it done at the beginning of
2019 but you know but this has been
Rachel den holders argument that this
extends beyond gymnastics to other
sports and absolutists is why Congress
has to get involved that there needs to
be a legislative remedy forcing this
type of database accountability almost
like a sexual predator list and about a
basis that we have yes I want parents to
understand how bad it is you gave two
very disturbing examples about the
coaching can you let us know what
exactly they had done sure
Gerald Murphy who is a taekwondo coach
in tallahassee florida had been
convicted of lewd and lascivious conduct
he'd been found in bed with his fourteen
his kids fourteen-year-old babysitter
he he was a teacher Florida pulled his
teaching credentials so he was not
allowed to be in schools but in 2014
somebody saw him coaching at a Taekwondo
event they knew about his felony
conviction they mentioned it to an
official or former official at USA
Taekwondo she mentioned it to the the
head people at USA Taekwondo and Suzanne
Lyons who will soon be the new chair of
the US Olympic Committee he was banned
but he continued to coach and he's still
advertising about that he's coaching to
yes I was what's so fascinating to me
too yes they know they're banned and yet
they're advertising look I'm still out
here working yes yeah
Jared Reneau Cates the the equestrian
coach he was posting things on Facebook
these these were not that's the thing
the six coaches that we found were very
easy to find they were there they're
hiding in plain sight if you want to if
you want to call it that posting on
Facebook posting on Instagram posting on
Twitter you can you can find these
people so what about the people who
aren't or that Robbie because they're
clearly getting a signal that the USOC
was not taking this as seriously as they
should have right how important is the
messaging coming from the USOC because
previously they said this is not our job
try invent sexual assault and abuse then
whose job isn't that's the question and
and
spend the problem with this system you
know if you look at other other sexual
abuse cases that we've had whether it's
the Boy Scouts the Catholic Church
somebody has had to take responsibility
somebody has had to take leadership and
that's what needs to happen now because
right now it's it's this hodgepodge of
policies and lists and if you're a
parent where do you go well you take
away for parents who have kids who are
involved in these sports is what today
don't assume that somebody has has
checked these people don't assume that
that somebody's keeping track of them
you have to do your due diligence and
and you've really got to be your kids
advocate because then what do i do Nancy
I don't even know what do I do
um you can check the safe sport list you
can go to the governing body of the
sports that your kids are involved in
though there's no guarantee that those
sports have lists or that they're public
but call the governing bodies call your
call the people who are running the
sports your kids are involved in and say
hey has this person the background
checked what do you know about this
person you know be aware of the people
who are working with your kids we just
want to read a statement from us a
Taekwondo that says this we are
currently involved in a legal process
that prevents us from commenting further
except to say that USA taekwondo
believes that education for parents and
athletes and everyone is safe and
positive experience so that the
statement from them let me ask you this
though what do you think is the next
step to fixing this journalism is doing
a great job by exposing this problem
what's the next step there has to be a
universal banlist there has to be one
place that everybody can go and say okay
is this person banned and then there's
gotta be enforcement there has to be
somebody who is following up to making
to make sure that once somebody is
banned they are not coaching alright
baby thank you
Thank You Nancy thank